earlier this week the games industry was
shocked to hear of the tragic early
passing of Nintendo CEO cetera whatta on
Sunday evening was when the new sort of
came through that he had sadly died of a
problem with a bile duct cancer i
believe on saturday night nintendo put
out an announcement and the world of
video games sort of reeled back and
thought about the impact that this one
individual had on an hour and our
beloved hobby Justin the news breaking
on Sunday where were you and you when
you heard it oh I was on my way back
from comic-con like I was literally in
the cab in one of our news guys Eddie
makuu texted me he was like satori wada
just passed away hmm um and I was I like
I'd have no idea what I'm what I should
do like cuz I'm on the cab on the way to
get like and and of course like we don't
want to take advantage of something like
that yeah it's such a huge thing like
you want to make sure that we are
honoring that memory and the right way
but also letting our audience know like
this is a huge important thing that that
just happened and and of course on
gamespot there was a lot of content that
we put around it because he has made
such a huge impact despite being someone
who are probably in recent years has
seen more corporate he spent the
president of Nintendo he's had a huge
impact in development of games and in
the shape of Nintendo for such a long
time it's like what are the ways that we
can honor that like we're not a
traditional news organization we don't
just have all these obituaries would
written although maybe we should start
doing that but that he was taken so
suddenly that here was a young guy 55
years is not old we knew that obviously
he was on well last year 83 he he had a
limited participation and this year of
course they did the sort of motif with
their Nintendo Direct of having him and
Reggie and everyone as puppets was there
ever any sort of concern on your guys
was there any like I never dawned on me
at the moment but presumably he's
actually been still sick this also the
last Nintendo Direct he looked much
thinner like it was noticeably thinner
and then when you had this sense into
directing that they didn't appear at all
it wasn't like a transition into puppets
it was literally a puppet e at the other
time like that definitely made us a
little bit more concern but he's at the
same time he's such a young person
like someone who can overcome something
like that that it was still quite a
surprise let's step away from the sort
of tragic event and and maybe framed
this or Center on this on on the
wonderful work he did during his his
life and his time in Nintendo and he
started off and was he working at Hal or
did he work on some games before he was
at how he started working on some games
on his own he famously picked up an HP
calculator and started programming games
and that kind of got him into it at a
time when being a game developer wasn't
a respected position especially in Japan
it was something you wouldn't admit and
he started working in Akihabara which is
the sort of nerds at the center of Tokyo
making games with his friends and
working at how he then ended up helping
Nintendo fix one of their games and
pinball and from there they had a really
good working relationship how actually
went under some financial issues and
Hiroshi Yamauchi who is the last member
of the founding family of Nintendo to be
the president of the company brought him
in brought Hal in because they had such
a good relationship and in 2002 yo mouth
she pointed satori wada as president of
Nintendo because he shared the same
lateral thinking when it came to
utilizing technology the sort of thought
that we always had to chase the bleeding
edge of tech is a losing battle to these
guys because there's always going to be
something better so they thought okay
how can we take technology that exists
and utilize that in an interesting way
and that was sort of how you know that
was the game boy that was the same thing
that uh gunpei yokoi via metro the game
boy game boy used to create that and
this was a lot of thinking when it came
to designing something like the wii mmm
they use existing harder from the
gamecube but it it tweaked it in a
different way and and that sort of
thinking is something that you wanna you
know carried with him but he was also
someone who was very passionate about
the creation of games not just the
business of games and who famously would
help you know he'd be walking around the
floor and watch people make games and
say no there's a problem with that and
sit down and start a program like the
president of the company walking behind
you takes your chair and does your job
for you but that's but that's because he
cares and he's knowledgeable and you
know he knows what he wants there was an
interesting anecdote he was on
gamecenter CX which is this japanese
program recently it needed an interview
with the guys and it's it's kind of a
fun program where they play video games
and he was talking about how his father
did not condone him playing like being a
video game designer like it's not a job
and he was like the interview was saying
well didn't that make you want to turn
away that you want to you know Japan
very respectful of your family
especially from his generation and he
was like no this is what I was
passionate about I want to make games
and this is what I cared about and it
paid off obviously that he's brought i
think more legitimacy to games than
anybody else like that's what nintendo
has done for us that as much as we think
of them as a kid system it's more that
they're friendly like they're in
everybody system and he's one of the
driving forces behind that yeah and he
came in obviously I would think was the
Gamecube all already sort of on the on
the way out by the time he came in but a
you know part of the teams who develops
and masterminded the wii the DS as well
his late you know two of perhaps the
most mainstream successful you know
consoles both in the house and handheld
of all time his later career involved
the 3ds which obviously had a lot of
problems he famously took a pay cut as
well after the investors call with the
sort of lack of success of the Wii U as
well and it is sort of sad that the last
two things that he was involved in ended
up being and parts of Nintendo that
perhaps didn't strike the iron quite as
hot as me today yeah and I don't know if
I'd say that about the 3ds the three
years definitely started out slowly but
it's picked up momentum so much it is
still the dominant hand held and it's
hard to reach the peak of what the d/s
was but it's definitely come a long way
did just like it's impossible to compare
yourself to the wii which was isn't that
transcended console with transcendent
gamers that became like a a mobile
device almost is that the wii u hasn't
lived up to that isn't surprising is
that just the nature of of be having
that mindset of being on the critical
agent trying things different is that
for every we you that you have you have
a wii for every every sort of dangerous
idea that didn't really take off you
have one that completely revolutionizes
in the industry I mean that's the risk
you take whenever you try to innovate
right i mean you really don't know how
things are going to pan out until you
give it a shot and sometimes you know
strike gold sometimes you find coal mmm
do you find quality give me a call
that's all positive right hit it you can
sell cold yeah sure yeah and i still
love playing my wii u as well I just I
don't know I kind of want to go back to
the fact that he took the pay cut you
know it never been an industry where
Studios tend to shudder when a game was
in duel or even when a game just
finishes and the company gets rid of
them we live in a world where CEOs get
shuffled where they pretend they did a
good job move on to the next company
yeah it was there for years and it's
something that's particular to Japan but
also at Nintendo where when you become
an employee at a company you're an
employee for life in most cases and when
you look at Nintendo and you look at the
people who are there you know and when
you consider your wada as well there is
sort of an old guard that was protecting
everything and and the fact that that he
it seems that he cherished the company
and his people enough because he had
been taken care of so well that he
sought to sort of payback you know that
that loyalty by by not getting rid of
people by doing what it took to keep the
company and his employees alive is is
remarkable and that just speaks to the
sort of person that that we've lost and
I think why it means so much it's not
just that he was a well-known person is
that he was a well-known person who was
respected and respected his peers yeah
what do you think finally this means for
the future of Nintendo obviously with
the NX presumably will see it in 2016
the future of Nintendo with their
partnerships in mobile and whatnot I'm
sort of a that's been a carrot on a
stick for a lot of people a lot of
companies recently in the immediate
direction but we're not going to see any
change in it next year or the year after
that even like any kind of change will
take years to because the Nintendo
itself has always been a slower moving
company as we've seen but at the same
like it does of course make me worry a
little bit like that awada is someone
who came from the ranks he's like
Miyamoto he's a designer he's a creator
and he was able to speak to that side of
being a president and i hope that
Nintendo continues with that that the
next person who comes into that role is
is equally passionate equally creative
than I I imagine Nintendo has to keep up
that idea that I wouldn't think that
they would ever bring in someone who's
like I and now we're gonna monetize the
[ __ ] out of this like I think both as
respect out to his memory and
out of respect to the type of company
that they are and it wasn't particular
to just do wat it wuz that's what
Nintendo was about and he was a an
amazing representation of that and I
think that they'll find somebody who
will continue that same legacy I hope
they will I think it's going to be a
massive challenge for them to do that
it's you know they've been so lucky over
the years to have people who are so
passionate about the company and about
gaming at large I don't think that's
easy to replicate I don't think that's
easy to put out like a call for a job
like we need these qualities like that
that's something you prove through years
of dedication and struggle yeah and I
don't know who at Nintendo can do that I
don't think Miyamoto is suitable for
that role at this point in career if I
don't think he wants to know I don't
know some sent ya like it's way too late
for that for him to take over in that
capacity so I don't know who at Nintendo
is well he's really there I mean we
don't see that many people I think that
a good fit would be someone like me I'm
just gonna throw my head out there if
you want to knit him the president it's
a thing and we may look back at this in
three or four years five years and think
this was the end of one ERA of Nintendo
I guess we'll have to wait and find out
Justin Peter thank you so much for
coming on and thanks to a wottus on as
well for all the wonderful video games
and consoles that we enjoy playing may
rest in peace
you